buenas noches espera que el presidente
donald trump hable de los temas
relacionados con política exterior
creación de empleo que desarrolle más su
plan para crear un millón de empleos en
los próximos 10 meses también que hable
de las relaciones con otras naciones
alrededor del mundo el liderazgo de los
estados unidos y también inmigración
pero uno de los temas más esperados será
el manejo que ve el presidente a la
crisis de el coronavirus ya que la
convención encabezada por el partido
republicano han revelado dos de las
principales propuestas lograr una vacuna
para el mes de diciembre pero también
que para 2021 ya esté completamente
normalizada la situación en eeuu así que
se espera que el presidente aborde aún
más este tema durante el discurso que
dará desde los jardines de la casa
blanca y tendrá decenas de invitados a
pesar de estar en medio de una pandemia
como hemos visto anteriormente
muchos de estos invitados a la casa
blanca no utilizan máscaras así que
envía un mensaje claro y también
blanca a pesar de las críticas por
utilizar edificios del gobierno para
fines partidistas en medio de una
campaña por supuesto el tema central
serán las críticas a su contrincante yo
bailé